[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
now so far we've been on the air what
two years now many challengers zero
winners nobody has caught us making a
mistake I guess I'm good
well tonight a fan with the YouTube
handle dr. cool beans thanks that he has
caught a mistake he says it happened
during a recent monologue in which I
described that nights audience
hello Conan you don't know me but I know
you and you made an error in your
Wednesday monologue you described the
audience as going to the wrong taping
and acting as if they were at a taping
for a WWF contest that was incredible I
think we've got the wrong show yeah yeah
no kidding they think they're at a WWF
well unfortunately Conan that means that
they would be attending a World Wildlife
Fund contest and I don't think they have
those maybe what you're referencing was
the WWE which is World Wrestling
Entertainment and I don't think Annie
approves that very much no she doesn't
not one bit
dr. cool beans I've never seen an animal
more desperate to escape its mass
there's a look on that dog's face that
says I put the lotion in the basket
what do you still won't let me go well
guess what dr. cool beans if that is
your real Christian name there is what
kind of doctor are you
yeah there is a World Wildlife Fund
contest in fact we have it booked on the
show tonight here we go look at that
very excited what what's this turtle is
turtle is tagging in with a folding
chair
Tiger is in trouble and I needs help
this is really tremendous oh look at
that
Oh tiger needs help putting on it single
[Applause]
and single and Tiger it's a god
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry that seagull did nothing to
help in that wasn't it supposed to hit
something well it it was nearby it was
nearby
well that was lame anyway the challenge
still stands if you think you've spotted
an error on our show reported a team
koco.com / haha i found an error we will
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes
go ahead chutney how do the boys show